Creed's got gets thrown in over the
years with like they're always become
things that get so big that then they
kind of get
not kind of put on a list of that it's
like
not cool or something like Nickelback
got put their Dane Cook got put there
there was a list that came out just
recently of like the 10 uncoolus bands
Nirvana was on the list right it's like
crazy it's crazy right that's crazy but
there's a thing that happens in society
yeah I notice it where something gets so
big that a generation later it becomes
like a thing where it's not cool right
you know for of course it's not that
cool anymore anyway because it's it's
time is like you know it was in a
certain era of time and stuff so it's
still but you know what I'm talking
about again like no I know exactly what
you're doing what is it and it's funny
I've talked about this before you know I
went from being on the cover of
magazines with the headline you know
Scott Stapp is this Summer's rock and
roll savior
to you know
the worst band of all time
people say like Nickelback Dane Cook
people say use these things that were
like hit like a level of of stardom
right well you you know what it it what
is it it wasn't it wasn't
America it wasn't the people of the
world it was the press and it was the
critics and and the media who have this
or have had this control
over the hearts and minds of the
population you know and and program in
your mind you know what's acceptable
what's not what's cool what's not and
they can turn on you in a dime if you
don't play by their rules yeah or or if
you get so big they fear they can't
control you anymore
um and so that's what happened there was
a shift especially when uh you know the
the Christian narrative came out and and
there is some deliberate uh you know all
throughout my music Christian references
and and references to Salvation and
those were intentional
um but when you're doing that in the
Devil's Playground and you're doing that
in secular he's gonna fight back music
um yeah and on every level uh you know
with the Press personally
um you know and uh you know so there was
a takedown uh and and now it's coming
back around you know I'm I'm proud I'm a
meme yeah oh it's cool how many people
get to be a meme [ __ ] you know what I
mean like and it was so funny when I saw
or not when I saw one day I was driving
my my nephew
and my son my oldest son Jagger uh to
either school or some practice or
something and they were giggling in the
back seat I was like what are you guys
laughing at and they were just kept
laughing and then all of a sudden I hear
we're home and then my nephew just busts
out laughing you know what I mean and my
own son who I wrote the song about is
making fun of me mimicking my voice
and I was like what and and now this was
before everyone else was doing it yeah
you know what I mean like you know
because the last 10 years it's really
become like a a thing you know
um and uh I uh
never thought that you know thank you
I'm glad man how many people get to get
get to have that and be a part of a
generation yeah people and tie into a
new generation yeah man I'm blessed
thank you and now my daughter wants to
wear Creed shirts to school and she's
learning Mark Germany guitar riffs on
her Les Paul it's cool yeah
um well I think he's going through that
system I think it's like there was that
like yeah just if for some reason it's
like that roulette ball landed on you
guys it sure did it seemed like and this
is from a outsider's perspective and
then but now it's like I told a lot of
people you were coming I was excited and
all them were [ __ ] stoked you know so
it was cool it was like man oh I want to
know like what is Journey's been like
what's going on
um so yeah I think like you're saying
it's like to even be able to have any
still relevance to see your daughter to
see people wearing your shirts with like
you know I'm sure I mean she's 15. yeah
and it's crazy how these young people
yeah they have like a different respect
the 90s are making a comeback yeah
um and uh it's just it's just crazy and
and and again I I have such gratitude
for that
um and also I have a sense of humor
about the the mimicry and and the jokes
and the jokes
um I I do it myself yeah
um because it's funny some of them are
funny man I got a sense of humor they're
good
um because what I found that happens is
it starts it started that way but then
people started digging in and going well
what are people what are they what are
people making fun of right and they
start listening to the music and then
that's when it gets out of my hands and
I say that God used me despite myself ah
and then the music goes boom and I
remember hearing I think it was
who was it it wasn't Jimmy Kimmel who's
the other guy
Cordon or whatever no no uh
uh oh wow I can't believe my mind just
went blank Seth Meyers no black hair oh
wow black hair uh Reggie Jackson no not
Reggie Jackson man it's uh late night
show there he is Jimmy Fallon oh Jimmy
Fallon yeah thanks for the reminder
sorry Jimmy my mind went blank dude
you're incredible but he was talking one
time on his show I think when he when he
uh his his wife was pregnant or they
just had a baby and he had been a Creed
mocker uh for a time because it was
funny it was good for stand up right
um and he went to get diapers if I'm
remembering the story correctly
and Arms Wide Open came on in in Walmart
or Target yeah wherever he was and he
finally got it uh it finally hit him as
a father but he had to become a father
to connect with the track
and you know and and you know I'm
blessed
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one